last week I covered the story of Arturo
Sanchez being accused of late payment as
well as scamming money from tournaments
that he ran on majorino well I've
finally been able to speak to both
matarino and Arturo and I think I have
the answers
[Music]
if you guys see this video and you enjoy
it why not drop us a like maybe
subscribe to the channel we like doing
stories like this and we hope that you
like that too cheers at the end of the
last video matrino said that they wanted
to speak with me after they addressed
the situation in a live stream that live
stream fell through though and they
agreed to speak to me directly so I
ended up interviewing matrino's head of
product Ryan cortaid and you may
recognize him from a certain online card
game firstly they told me that match
Reno is not Banning Arturo from
participating in events that have a
match Reno page as a player he simply
cannot organize on the platform going
forward yeah on our side moving forward
I think we've been clear that you know
Arturo will not be
organizing events on matrino anytime in
the future
for our tournament organizers that we
work with
they can work with him or have them in
their tournaments we're not trying to
dictate anything that they're doing
[Music]
it's just that on our side you know
since he broke TOS has been banned he
will not be allowed to use
a plot the platform for organizing
events there is a way for TOS to pay out
a player without a match Reno account
via email when the event is finalized
and furthermore they told me that
they're looking into creating account
types that would allow player only
permissions but not organizer
permissions that doesn't currently exist
though matrino also confirmed to me
later that if Arturo wants to stream a
tournament that has a matrino page well
that's between him and the to they're
not asking for him to be banned from
activities like that either secondly
based on the receipts I've seen of text
messages as well as a timeline that was
provided to me it was the people who use
matrino who came to the company saying
listen something has to happen here and
paying people is one of the core things
that match Reno does and from the
receipts they tried to find a way to
help Arturo pay the money back
immediately knowing that once the money
was repaid this issue would be done for
his part art said that he was in the
hospital with his dad during this
stretch but then as soon as the
statement went out he paid nearly
immediately thirdly as Arturo claimed
matrino did commit to making an
announcement after everything was paid
off but this statement was contingent on
Art taking responsibility for his
actions and ultimately once other
accusations started to fly they didn't
feel comfortable saying that he had paid
back everything because well they didn't
know that for sure plus more events were
immediately discovered that same day
though to Arts Credit he was able to pay
for those amounts again on December 30th
matrino did confirm to me however that
Arturo has paid them back for the
amounts that they paid out to the
players and as of this moment barring
any new information that we're currently
not aware of those events are paid up
art is paid up with match Arena actually
it turns out that he sent them like 400
too much apparently lastly matrino told
me that the delay in addressing this
situation was twofold we had plans to go
on a different community
podcast that did not pan out we also
wanted to be as thorough as possible on
our side there's a lot of parties
involved and as everyone knows there's a
lot of events that have been organized
by Art and
we just wanted to you know dot our eyes
and cross our T's before making a
statement I criticized their initial
statement for being vague which it is
but in matrino's view it was Arturo's
statement that would clarify exactly
what had happened he would be the one
talking about the late payment at make a
statement but at the same time also
let Arturo handle it himself how he
wanted to with the community since we
know that you know he's a big part of
the community and that he's been in it a
long time again I don't think his
initial tweet explains what happened
very well so I do have some sympathy for
this view let's go through what did
happen based on matrino's receipts the
receipts do paint a pretty bleak picture
of payments from June 21st 2022 to
September 27 2022 lots of tournaments
that art was organizing on matrino went
unpaid this included 17 can opener
series Pages as well as some pages for
big games at tournaments like defend the
north all told the initial estimation
was that art was on the hook for about
sixty three hundred dollars in
tournament winnings receipts of Discord
messages previously made public from
before December 12th show players
reaching out to Art to get him to pay
but he didn't actually do that at the
time in at least one of these cases can
opener number 64 all three players were
listed as participants in the event so
they could have been paid out directly
to their match Reno wallets art claims
that he paid out to himself because he
needed to verify the winners before
paying out matrino also made it clear to
me that they have very high site up time
they claim 99.95 over the past year and
that the claims from art and others at
matrino makes it hard to pay out are
true Arturo's initial response to the
situation
surprised us
because
there was a lot of things that he
expressed like difficulty of making
payments and things such as this that we
had never heard before and that he had
not relayed to us this situation doesn't
get to match Reno until December 12th
when a tournament organizer notes that
several of their events had not been
paid out at this point it was several
months that these payments had been late
the very next day mastering a CEO Grant
Farwell calls Arturo and according to
them he says that he will pay the money
back he also noted that some of the
defend the north events had already been
paid by him before that conversation in
the meantime match Reno was starting to
hear that other sources were aware that
these tournaments hadn't been paid out
on December 18th five days after art
initially said he'd pay the players
Grant and art text again Grant says he
hopes to quote not have this be a major
blow up end quote art was aware based on
these texts that matrino felt like they
needed to make a statement if they
couldn't get the money where it needed
to be soon they exchanged bunch of texts
between the 19th and the 22nd and
neither side disputes these so I'm not
going to go Point by Point really the
timelines match up on both sides but on
the 23rd a legal notice is emailed to
Arturo he claims that it was sent to the
wrong email
um match Reno can test that and they say
that they told Art that the notice was
coming and they told him when and where
to expect It ultimately though based on
text messages he did know that legal
action was a possibility and that it
would need to start soon if they
couldn't get this thing sorted matrino
also paid out the remaining events
themselves on the 23rd and you can see
some shell Pages for those payouts here
on December 29th matrino says Arturo
sent them 300 on PayPal without letting
them know or saying anything art says it
was a payment in good faith and that it
happened actually on the 30th might be
time zone Shenanigans not really that
important to be honest the next day we
got the matcharino tweet and arts
response Grant and art talk on the phone
art sends sixty three hundred dollars to
match Reno on PayPal 40 minutes after
the initial statement more events are
identified as unpaid that day and so
after that initial sixty three hundred
dollar payment Arturo transfers a total
of another twenty five hundred dollars
to match Reno in various PayPal
transactions and from the first video
you know the rest of the story and
matrino hasn't made a statement about
this situation until they spoke with me
for this video so why did I go over late
payments well for one thing the issues
of paying out to sell which has been
very much focused on by the community
and also the accusation of skimming
payments aren't things that matrino is
planning to pursue at this time for one
thing the payout to self is something
that match Reno is already aware of they
knew that Arturo had this ability and in
fact his account was flagged so that if
he did it it wasn't going to just show
up in the system as a huge problem so
that is in the breach of the terms of
service we can just move on past the
point of paying out yourself now in
terms of taking a cut it seems like it
mostly happened off the website using
PayPal although match Reno still
contests and I agree that this should be
done transparently through the site
where everyone can see it
if a tournament organizer says that they
and art are square and the players also
agree with that assessment there's not
really anything materino can do that
kind of leaves the issue of late payment
as the only thing to talk about and I
think we should talk about it the reason
I think we should is because well art
did really up here and matrino for
their part tried to find a solution
where this didn't go public and I think
the community deserves to know about
that art said he was in the hospital
with his dad who was really sick and
that's a really terrible situation that
no one should have to go through but
let's be honest not paying for months
beforehand is the mishandling of funds
in the statement and I don't think
calling it a massive misunderstanding is
very accurate based on the attempts from
matrino to get him to pay or to admit
that he couldn't so they could so on our
side
um we were hoping that he would not only
admit to the late payments but also
admit to taking the money into his own
paper account and no longer having it to
pay the players Arturo understood that
he needed to pay and that legal would be
involved if he didn't but he didn't pay
not until they made that statement and
then he paid almost immediately the
company tried to do right by their
stakeholders and Arturo by handling this
responsibly but at a certain point
enough is enough we're a financial
platform transparency and Truth in our
system is most important we're going to
investigate this we actually released
our two weeks prior to the announcement
so regardless of the pressure to from
the TOs maybe to make a statement you
could say right or something like this
but in terms of just like handling the
situation irregardless of the Tas if we
have a report of misconduct we're going
to investigate that period like you know
there's no other way about it so why the
hell did everything else happen again
matrino said that they needed art to
make a statement that would clarify what
had happened responsibility for the
things he had done wrong notably the
late payment and I see their point that
once they saw these other accusations
come in it was impossible to just say
yeah he paid everything back they needed
to check that but again today they're
confirming that as far as they can tell
today the events that were late are all
paid out some of them were paid by
Arturo himself many more were paid by
matching on the 23rd when they set up
these shells to pay out outstanding
events and then like I said on December
30th Arturo transferred money from his
Paypal to match Arena to pay for the
outstanding amounts there was a lot more
I want to say about matrino in this
report because this entire situation has
led people to make some pretty bold
claims about the company and I had to
ask them about it but two takeaways for
me after speaking with them is firstly
they don't sell their users data and
secondly the claim that they're
insolvent they also deny I also don't
think it's possible to look at these
receipts and claim that match Reno was
acting maliciously one other thing that
people pointed to was that Arturo's
majorino account one of them at least
appeared to be banned mid-stream when he
was doing his initial ill-fated response
stream matrino told me this was an
unfortunate mistake so he has two
accounts that that account was banned by
somebody who wasn't watching actually in
the middle of the stream
um unfortunately but if he had managed
to go to his wallet I don't know exactly
what he was trying to show people he
actually pulls up the account prior in
the video and realizes like he's about
to do something and he realizes like
holy if I go to my when you go to
your profile you have to go to the top
right and then you have to click profile
but when you do that if you have a
balance it tells you the balance of your
account right there that's another thing
I've lost over too in that stream that I
mentioned Arturo said that the money was
in the match Reno but I've been able to
confirm that first of all those payments
that he made on December 30th were made
from PayPal and secondly while there may
have been a small balance in an account
it certainly was nowhere near the those
amounts that were sent on December 30th
where does this leave Arturo though
while macharino confirmed to me again
that if he wants to enter a tournament
that has a matrino page as a player
they're not stopping him from doing that
obviously tournament organizers allow
players to play in their events at their
own discretion and if he does want to do
that and tournament organizer is okay
with it there is an option to pay him
out via email in the system that's what
they'll have to use for now because he
doesn't have an account and if a
tournament organizer wants him to stream
a tournament that has a matrino they're
okay with him doing that as well side
note this is a classy move from matarino
and it really is not the behavior of a
company that's trying to destroy someone
secondly Arturo remains banned from East
Coast throwdown at the time of this
video as well as some other events I'm
not going to go over all of them but
here's the thing a tournament organizer
could probably ban whoever they want for
whatever reason they want as long as
it's not a discriminatory one or
something but what I'm trying to say is
this if tournament organizers banned him
because the perception is that he stole
money well the money is finally where it
needs to be according to both Arturo and
match Reno based on available
information now it took a long time and
it really shouldn't have but it is there
now
ball is in their Court basically but it
seems like both sides want to move on
from this because well that's what both
sides wanted initially they just
couldn't make it happen in a reasonable
time frame in private then when it made
public additional accusations from
elsewhere in the fgc like the paying out
to self or skimming accusations made the
thing take substantially longer and get
a lot weirder now that the money is
where it needs to be and we've got the
receipts we can make our own decisions
about what happened let's just make sure
that they're informed decisions on our
side we really wanted to clear up a lot
of the confusion in public because it's
causing not only our company Strife you
know people at our company have been
receiving threats but also between our
partners there's a lot of you know
talking and fighting over this type of
thing and since we have the information
we just want to make it pop click so
that you know we could be fully
transparent
and additionally moving forward we're
looking to make some improvements as
well that would make it more obvious not
only where your money's going when you
donated it including the prize pool
breakdown that's already on the event in
the contribution modal but additionally
making some changes so that if someone
who is Staff gets paid out they're
clearly labeled
but mostly matrino's just looking to
clear up
a lot of the public claims that we don't
think are accurate thank you for
covering thank you to support Esports
for covering my side of the story thank
you to everybody that supported me even
though um it looked bad for me I hope
people I hope we can have closure on all
this and I hope people can see both
sides of the story and under the
understand the facts from an objective
uh Viewpoint I want to say I'm sorry FTC
once again and um I hope they realize
that I've made incredible sacrifices for
the scene for the last 25 years and you
know I love this community and I hope
they'll give me a chance to like uh move
on
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock